[Music]
i ruled
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos
and uh today
i'm going to talk about a character
that is uh out of this world
today i bring you xm studios
beta ray bill now
the reason why i got the statue is
because
he represented a pinnacle
of thor comic books
but i'm getting ahead of myself let me
go back to
when walter simonson
probably one of the best dynamic
uh artists to ever hit marvel
and he took his turn at the mighty thor
and i remember because at this time thor
get was getting a little bit stale and
[Music]
he came on and i believe his issue 337
picked it up uh and on the cover the
cover it was a dynamic cover because it
had
this weird dude busting the the cover
open
with a hammer this guy
so when i saw it
i was like what's what's going on so i i
i
read the book and
i was absolutely taken aback by
uh what was going on what transpired you
know nick fury called
donald blake and and this time donald
blake
is the persona of the mighty thor right
uh remember odin send him to earth and
uh you know to to make him learn a
lesson
anyway so donald blake uh goes to shield
and uh there's a spaceship that is
approaching earth
now when nick fury said that spaceship
was approaching earth that had did
something in a
past galaxy like sucked up a star or
something like that
and you know thor donald blake
hit his cane on the floor turned into a
millionaire
shot off into space he intercepted the
spaceship
when he intercepted the spaceship uh
that's beta ray build spaceship
it's called the scuttlebutt right and
it's sentient it's alive
so thor didn't know this thor
automatically assumed that what it was
uh uh just you know a regular ship
so he goes in now
he sees like a cryogenic chamber
and the ship wakes up bill they'll bust
out
grabs door by the face and start
fighting him the hammer drops now
remember
after 60 seconds he turns back into
donald blake
so they tussling and they're fighting
and their hammer turns
back into the stick so you know
beta ray bill's looking for the hammer
his weapon thor's weapon
and he picks up the stick
and he like you know goes to you know
throw it and hits the wall bangs the
wall
he turns into like beta ray thor
like what so it was a crazy issue
um and then he goes on to fight thor
uh for the power of milner because you
know
odin called him back to asgard
and they found out that he wasn't a bad
guy see the thing with
uh beta ray bill is uh he's a genetic
engineered uh carbonite
right so he has dna of carbonite mixed
with
one of their apex predators on their
planet and
uh he he had to go through extensive
training
uh beating people and different type of
feats and stuff like that to even
achieve
the level of becoming their guardian
their
guardian warrior so in doing so
uh he is cybernetically enhanced
here's the apex of his uh
his race and he
they took his soul and placed it into
this body
which is crazy within itself right the
whole
the whole story behind him is crazy with
himself walt simonsen has forever made a
character
that is imprinted in
the marvel pantheons you know he was the
first person to pick up thor's hammer
and actually weld it so milner so
and in doing so it was it was insane
well actually he beat thor in the fight
uh
odin because there was is for the there
was fighting for the hammer
so odin said you know wouldn't be right
if he didn't you keep the hammer beta
ray bill relinquished the hammer to thor
because that was you know thor's and
odin uh got the elves to make
him a hammer which is stormbreaker
so that's how you got stone breaker but
i digress let's get into the statue
first
i love art prints
from xm they give you some of the best
art prints
and they're absolutely wonderful
uh this is depiction of the actual
statue
the statue itself we're going to start
with the base
the base is sorter soda is if you still
throw a ragnarok you saw the big giant
fire beast
well that's who that is now
it's a history that beta ray bill has
because the carbonites
uh sort of send his demon horde against
the carbonites in space
so that's it was like a little bit of
lineage there so
the baits itself is sorta's face it's
crazy
you put your hand in his mouth his
tongue is there you see the textures
because he's supposed to be on fire
molten
it's a very intricate great
base that he's standing on he sits in
with one peg
and it's the front lead le uh
left leg peg and no right leg pick
and his body is
supremely heavy the cape is a molded
cape it's not a fabric cape you know we
talked about mixed media here before
mixed media is when it's fabric that's
not fabric that's all
molded and then you go up to the switch
outs he has multiple switch
outs he has uh this uh
what is this this is the 413 uh hammer
of stormbreaker and
in his other arm up there he has the 616
that's the marvel continuum that we know
the continuity that we know
he has one where he has his arm
outstretched like he's calling for the
hammer
so you can actually display him in a
main rid of different
uh poses because of the switch out
also he has two portraits the portraits
themselves
one is with an open mouth and the head
positioning is different and then you
have
this closed mouth one where he's
gritting his teeth like he's about to
swing the hammer
it's a very good option to have
i just use this one right now because
i'm going to be using the open mouth one
now what i've noticed is the wings on
the ears i can't see
a discernable difference between the two
because they come
separate and they're very finely
detailed
i really appreciate that that means it
took time they didn't cheap out on you
and give you uh you know weak wings on
the ears
it's definitely a beautiful thing to see
if i'm gonna like rate the statue
because
i have the brick of brimstone thor and i
think both of them
actually work really well together you
know because he's fighting sure there
and he's fighting sort of here it's it's
it's a good companion piece
i just feel that this statue is more
robust it's
larger stronger because uh being this
one full scale he is
actually you know bigger than thor
itself anyway
because i think he's six seven so
absolutely insane character
uh the muscle definition is ridiculous
the textures the belt everything is
molded a very
very solid piece this is the reason why
i believe
xm is like the bmw of statues
fantastic stuff so this is the part in
the video
where i'm gonna ask you to like follow
and subscribe
and hit that join button hit the joy
button
you know where that join button is that
join button is right there
down at the bottom hit that join button
so you can be part of the realm
and when you're part of the realm you
have uh backstage
passes to everything that we do as far
as sweepstakes and everything like
playstation 5
xbox series x we also give those away
also go to lordsofgaming.net where we
have a ton of writers
opinion pieces and everything that you
want to know about
next generation current generation and
the future
we cover it all you can also get old
episodes of kos there
well i think we're up to like 65 right
now so go digging the crates go check
that out
also have combat talk with the king and
we also
have old episodes of iron lords podcast
which i'm a member of
you can catch that sundays at 11am
during football season
oh my god 1pm eastern standard time
normal and i can't wait to get back to
that this football season has to end
it's killing my sundays and also the
last word with lol cognito and ibontas
that goes up every friday so definitely
check that out because destiny
is inside game pass right now and that
uptake of all the people that are
playing it right now
i've never seen so many new people in
all my life
well stick around watch this video today
i did something a little bit different
because i had to unbox it because i had
got it in from ebay
this is the ebay purchase so i had to
unbox it quickly just to check the
package so
this one you're not going to get the
unboxing but you're going to get
a whole build up of the statue so
definitely stick around
watch it see all the switch outs and
leave your feedback down in the comment
section and i'll talk back to you see
you next week
when i bring you something
made of steel stay
collected
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you